um for those that uh don't don't know me
uh
i'm a very blunt person
they've said
it's nice because when i go to america
and it sounds stupid it shows how naive
i am they say you're really candied and
i'm going what's candid mean
so then you'll get somebody who
understands where they go that means
you're blunt
and so so i'm either candid or blunt but
it all boils down to
um
there's some book coming
there's some books um down there
and uh
if anybody's interested they're 10
pounds each but the second book
hasn't really been a very successful one
as far as sales goes it doesn't matter
i'm not trying to become a jk rowling
but um it's more about the spiritual
path
and uh today what i want to do is i want
you to
i purposely didn't bring the mats that's
easy to bring them they're easy to put
together but today i want you to get to
the point of throwing but not to throw
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to spend the next 10 15 minutes giving
you a biography
to tell you how we get here today
those of you who have been watching
youtube films of great masters and
people over the years you'll notice that
there's not one who's the same they're
all different and if i said to any of
you from different styles we'll say
shia nagi
ekio
nobody flinches because you just know
what i'm talking about
but if we had four people stand up and
do it with their partner
not one of them would be exactly the
same
performed as the other and that's what
makes you and me individuals
so my book the eyes of a child
comes from when i was young
and i remember my uncle buying me a
watch because he wanted he about seven
years of age he wanted me to tell the
time
i wasn't at all interested in telling
time i was interested in just being a
being a kid you know
and now two weeks later watch was in the
draw
the novel had worn off and that's where
it stayed
when i got to 11 or 12 i went to work
with my father
and everybody kept saying what you're
going to do when you grow up
so i found the pressure of adults on a
child
um
so i must have been quite smart i suffer
from dyslexia but i must be quite smart
because what i realized was as long as i
agreed with them or went along with
their what they want me to be
a carp into an electrician or you know
whatever they were saying at the time or
what they wanted me to be
i used to go yeah i might do that
but in my head and tony said i'd say
i don't know what i'm going to be
i'm not going to let them force me into
being something i don't want to be
now we all have this ability even today
but what's happened is the world has
twisted us and changed us and made us
become another sheep in the herd and we
have to conform to certain things rules
regulations
so when i was 23 i was running my own
business in a little shed
and the guy wanted me who broke down
this is my first book i think
but the vehicle broke down
uh it was one of his workers when he
come when the boss come to pay me he
said i've got four vehicles one three
vans and i've got a rover car if you
want my business for a year i'm trying
to get
aikido students for a new 12-week class
i'll give you my business for a year if
you come to the 12-week aikido class
so i jumped at it because i went in the
business yeah i'll be there i'll be
there knowing in my head
i'll make some excuse when it comes to
wanna i'll just say oh i couldn't make
it we've all been there you know
so i'm when i'm talking i'm hoping i'm
talking to all of you as you
the time cut the night come
and i forgot about the i forgot that i'm
supposed to do this but i used to walk
across the road to the pub of two pints
of beer walk back to work carry on
get home about 10 o'clock
this night
i run out of work
i run out of work i went over the pub at
six o'clock door was locked
i said oh blast he said from this week
he wouldn't be opening until seven got
in my car really annoyed because i used
to like a pint
drive to the next village
door was locked
went home
crossed said to my wife what about my
tea how long is my tea going to be
because i was a real male show of this
pig then
but still are um
she said you got him too early i didn't
know he was gonna be i'm early we didn't
have mobile phones them days
put the television on you just you just
have to get out there and push buttons
to change the channels there was nothing
on the telly
it was 17 miles
from my
workshop to where i lived
and i sat and i suddenly thought oh
there's that thing on
now as odd of places when you get a map
the oddest of places the place where the
course was was only two miles from my
house
it was like
talk about odd
luck or fate
so anyway i went there
they were small tables because it was a
junior school
and all i remember was all night he hit
my head because whoever this karate guy
was who was doing the aikido kept
following me and i said end up under a
table so all night i remember hitting my
head on the top
from that day on i didn't stop for 23
years
i loved it
so
i don't know about you know you people
you've driven you've come here today but
i don't want a an imitation of that
tripod
if i know
that there's uh
let's say the mona lisa of tripods i
want the mona lisa tripod that's the way
i've always been even if i have to save
up for it
so they said look if you want really to
learn aikido you've got to drive to
london
so i decided that i would drive to
and train a place called the hut it's a
pub and at the back of it it's got a
building not as not as quite as big as
this
so i want to tell you a bit about that
aikido first started in hillingdon at
the hut
and it was uh there was a judo and a
boxing school
and a famous judo man very famous
student a man
[Music]
kenshiro abby
he come to teach them judo
but he said i've just been
uh chewing and i've met this
this little old man oh sensei who's
doing this new art called aikido he's
showed me some things and it's really
fascinating and i'm going to show you a
little bit but what i'll do is i'll if
you're interested i'll send over mr
nakazano who's training a lot more than
what i have in the art
so nakazano came over and they enjoyed
it so much they stopped boxing and judo
and and made it into an aikido school
it was run by a man called uh
ken williams
who was welsh and he then finally
decided to go back to wales and he left
it to his right hand person who was
hayden foster
so when i was started training in 1973 i
got to orange belt and i thought i need
more i need more so i started driving to
every sunday morning
regardless of weather conditions
to train on a sunday
until you as a brown belt you couldn't
train on the monday and then you could
train with weapons but you weren't
allowed to touch a weapon until you was
the first you
so don't matter how much i begged and
pleaded and told me how far i'd come
you wait till you're around about before
you so what i done was i bought
in
1975 cytosenses
cine films and a book series that he
made
and when the wife used to go out i'd put
the films on
and then because i weren't sure what
he'd done i'd turn the set projector
back
and i would um watch it backwards and
forwards and backwards and forwards and
then i'd open my patio doors and i'd
start playing it and trying to follow it
so nobody knew that i was an always
about starting to do weapons
i got my first dan i i went there in the
end for 10 years non-stop
and i used to go on a sunday and
occasionally on a monday when i reached
the queue great first q
when i got my second down
they stopped using me as uk
and of course if you drive all that way
you you know you get the buzz at her you
know said to use me as okay
your ego's uh good
but they saw you so i said to my mate
julian
why don't they use me anymore he said
because you're making them look bad they
can't throw you anymore
you're becoming too grounded
so i was upset because i i genuinely my
little child's mind was hurt because i
thought well what do i do
you know i don't know
i don't want to be dishonest to myself
you know if they say attack me then
you know attack them if they say grip me
i grip them
and i couldn't understand
what i'd got to do and it was i don't
know if my dyslexia or whether it's uh
even at 71 i've still got the mind of a
child because if i see something wrong i
just go but that's wrong and then i
might go oh
i shouldn't have said bachelor so i'm
not one to think about my words first if
the pitch is wrong the picture's wrong
and i think you'll all agree
that we don't like to be told off or we
don't like honesty or truth
but
it's easier than me trying to think how
shall i put this to them
because really i'm
i'm doing your disservice by
saying good well done just because
you've driven all this way that's good
well done you know see cytosense he said
if you cut a thousand times with a ken
thinking you'll get better
then it'll take me more than a thousand
to unpick it and to make it right so he
said i have to stop you quickly that's
why i shout at you because if i can stop
you quickly then we can correct it
quickly
so i pretty much have this theory now
i'm going to just go back a little bit
so my friend emigrated to new zealand
and he said i don't like your style
following this side oh mr saito sensei
he said it's like a sausage factory
they're all
coming out the same
he said they're all like you know crab
style and it's awesome
but he said
he's coming over to us in new zealand
if you get an air ticket
i'll put you up i'll pay for the seminar
be great to see you we haven't seen each
other for so long
because he was at the hut and he was
like the
one down from mr foster
and um
so
i'd work with all the people in the club
and that bought an air ticket went over
to cytosensi
he heard that this person come away from
england
so he calls me up tony henka
yes
and he rocks
and even his
students
afterwards they said we've never seen
scentsy rock before like that but in
between that and a lot of you have heard
me say before and yeah i grabbed him and
he he rocks a bit and he goes like this
and the next thing i'm
in a time of anchor
then he calls me from royalty dory
and i'm thinking i've come all this way
on the second down i'm really good i've
been hooking a long time so he throws me
in my router dory
i get up ready
and he's not in front of me
he's there
he hadn't moved but he disorientated me
so that
i didn't know where he'd throw me and i
thought i didn't feel that what's this
about i'm grabbing him as hard as i can
he's just
he's invisible he's not invisible but
you're squeezing like a marshmallow
so
that whole week he said
you buy as much film as you can
film me
um and owning me
he only let me film him so i done that
but the power from the man
was incredible
you see and he didn't have to say
a little bit ease up a little bit you
know it would i was nothing to him
so you see me fiddling with this plastic
fork don't you so here's the story
i left the hut in the end
because
sensei said would you be my
representative for the uk
and i said i would but to do that i had
to really dissolve my self with the
heart
but we had a party
and he's sitting there
and he'd been given this big
uh maori costume and he sat there like
this big king and i was a giant compared
with him because he's japanese and so he
was big for japanese but he was small
compared to me
anyhow he he sitted there and he got
this big flat thing that you pump your
tea into and he got a mug and he kept
going
tea and he'd pass it to this person and
they'd pump him his tea and he'd go back
and i thought it was tedious see
and he was getting happier and happier
it was only tea in color mixed with
about two litres of vodka or whiskey or
something because he was a alcoholic and
that's the sad part of his life he was
an alcoholic
but what he done was there was a knee
down
maui lady who'd been too warm and
trained with them and i trained with
them she got them my smallest of hands
but once she grabbed hold of you even
though she couldn't get around it was
like a sucker that you couldn't get off
and she was really powerful
so psycho since he says
to this guy
get up and do coke and aggie with her
and he told her
grab him
so she grabbed him and he's throwing her
about everywhere and we were enjoying
the the demonstration it was really
powerful
and he goes no no no no no he said um
they say picks up this fork from the
party
and he's holding it at this end and he
goes
grab the of course
there's about 60 people all laughing at
him he gets really quite wild at this
point
he said i said grabbed a fork to this
girl in japanese
and of course she understood japanese
we thought it was a joke you see
and he's throwing her
several times
with the with the four
and he said that's how much
power you need to do those senses
he said and oh well this one ain't gonna
but he went like that that went tick and
broke he said and that's how much you
don't
and i thought
have i actually seen what i've just seen
because
how can you you know i mean this one's
flexible perhaps it made them different
over the years but he did he said that's
how much
power you need he said and that just
snapped in half he said that's how much
you don't need
so that stayed with me since um 1983
8283 that stayed with me
so that brings us right up to today
and this is why today
it doesn't matter john i think uh
perhaps somebody else but i think john's
been the longest
person
following me but i don't think
he could do that with a with a fork
i think i can but i don't know because i
haven't tried it because i
i just don't know i just haven't tried
it
but what i'd like to do is i'd like i've
never trained with nick you've been up
here once before i've never trained with
mark there's mark isn't it i'm telling
the name so please forgive me i've never
trained mark i've never trained matthew
so what i want to do is i want to
ask you
you've got to be open to this
i don't think you'll be able to do what
i
want you to do today so i want everybody
to take away something today that you
perhaps haven't taken away before and
that is the understanding
that your goal
is to use no strength
because it doesn't matter again mark
does it uh you might have senses style i
believe
like you know you've done
uh andy hathaway's
different stuff i've done so many
different styles but i've ended up with
cytosenses now why have i ended up with
his and i'm not trying to convert
anybody here
it's because
he's honest
and he said that people complicate
those senses
so
and again it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter about your style the
cameras might need my camera might need
some raising of it
we call that's what i use
it's called the art dawn resistance
isn't it do we do we pretty much all
know aikido's bugs with the art and on
the vision
just watch this first part of the fact
is where i go i go here don't i
okay you're here
okay
or i go here
yup with this foot forward or i go here
ah with this foot forward
so that's all i need to show you
so psychosensity says
if you understand that
you've got the angles of getting out of
the way so from now on
please go past because it should be the
art non-resistance so the the thing is
please go pass but when you get somebody
when you get somebody
and you go
that's not going past that's getting in
his way isn't it
um
a lot of
talking of scentsy uh yamada he taught
me a woman aggie without him knowing it
because cyto says he couldn't
but shomenuchi
it's just right because my angle was
here
but my angle was that angle
so when he comes but
it's the angle of the ken so the ken the
most basic of movements has taught me
all i need to know about aikido in other
words get out of the way
the art of non-resistance
the hong koo dojo have decided that they
do ikkyo
when he's coming down
that cannot go so i'm talking about my
simple child's mind now that cannot work
with this theory of please go past
if i'm going in hey
even though you see me doing it that's
hurting my wrist that's hurting my bone
so what am i going to do be quicker oh
perhaps it can't be quicker
it's going against the principles of
that fork
because and cytoskeleton would say
if zombie can't please get out of the
way
see i've got kodak
he said look why
why make it complicated when it can be
simple
so why
do this now go around his back bring him
around here and
do so
a lot of people
see so to me that makes sense and that's
why i followed him because
i could have a lot of contradictions
but that doesn't contradict itself you
see
so i'm not saying to anybody change your
aikido but but you should all have a
path that you want to follow mentally
and it's got to make sense if it doesn't
make sense why are you doing it well
you're doing it because you see people
like me who do wonderful pieces of like
a dagger wow
i want to be like that well that's how i
was when i was a even at 23. i want to
be like that i want to do that
so you
blindly get led
believing in these wonderful masters
but if i say to you in everyday life
look you run your own business
you run your own business um
you must make a lot of decisions in a
day you know common sense ones you must
have to decide sometimes under pressure
and yeah we're sort of a little bit
in front of an aikido master you know
wow
look what you can do
so we've become stupid when it comes to
logic
so today is all about saying
would you
if he'd got a sword in his hand
slowly would i would i
do because well yeah but i'd do a
different technique that's see that's
what people said to me over the years
yeah i do a different technique i go but
why don't you do a different one if it's
easier in the beginning see that's my
bluntness and that's my childishness of
why make it difficult if you don't have
to
so what i'm going to do is we're going
we're going to do kaitenagi you can do
this way or you can do this way i don't
mind what way you do
i want you to get to this point so
you'll choose your part if you haven't
already and and you'll have the amount
of the fork that i'm talking about in
both hands and you'll ask your partner
to stand up
no stand up
don't miss about
all right so so and i want you to feel
how much
power you have to use to hold them down
because that's where we're going today
i'm going to come around so you know i'm
going to say to you
how much have you got here stand up
how much can you
stop that because that that that's not a
lot of force
so that's it good okay good so the only
way he should be thinking of going when
you're done hopefully this technique the
only way you should be thinking of going
is
over that way
he should put himself into the akemi you
shouldn't have to do it you know we all
know that you bring the knee through or
you do various different forms
but
to get to here
there's a measurement there's a
measurement between
me here
and here
me here and here
and me here and here
this is the triangles of aikido and the
triangles of aikido
are only there
you could say yeah but that one's longer
but what i'm going to do now is with my
mind
i want to put them all together so if i
don't put them together stand up yes
if i put them together i'm gonna go
right link link link might just stand up
so you've got to use your mind
not the one other people want you to use
you've got to use your mind you've got
to go well i've got all the bits here
now i've got not so
may keep moving around my mind i've got
to
somehow link them
mentally and make them all one
i've got to do that with my mind i've
got to believe in something
okay so i've talked enough you don't
need to warm up really because uh we're
not going to be throwing
ok
we're going to move the chairs